[Musik]
hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video wir machen halt reporter
hätten ein andermal was sind
porsche-fahrer sind türkische brötchen
gefüllt mit käse und petersilie oder
oder anderen zu treten heute mal ein
ganz klassisches türkisches rezept
tatsächlich das grundrezept noch nie
gemacht schon aber nicht vor kamera und
diesmal einfach ein grundrezept und wir
führen mit käse und petersilie max ist
mit petersilie oder ohne mit mit geld
und dann machen wir noch die zweite
füllung nämlich eine pizza erfüllung
jetzt machen wir erstmal den hefeteig
dafür nehme ich den halben dürfe 200
gramm wasser zwei esslöffel zucker 2
weiß 2 mit zwei teelöffel salz 800 kamel
und 200 gramm sonnenblumenöl
nur diese zutaten lässt ich kam da
darfst du jetzt heute die zutaten in die
maschine schmeißt ihr könnt den teig mit
der hand weg nicken oder eben auch mit
der küchenmaschine
und erstmal hefe zucker und wasser kurz
verrühren
damit dies nicht so gut arbeiten kann
und
nicht gleich das salze zu geben denn die
hefe und das salz nicht ich gehe machte
wollte
seid ihr mit der maschine helfen ja so
macht das schon
[Musik]
den meisten ein bisschen mehr dazu aber
nicht alles
genau so und jetzt kannst du eigentlich
alle zutaten dazugeben eiweiß das eickel
frau ich später zum bestreichen auch
vorsichtig
und salz
und das öl geben wir noch zum schluss
dazu und dann noch das restliche mehl
und je nachdem was für mehl verwendet
kann sein dass ihr so bis zu 40 gramm
mehr oder weniger mehr gebraucht da
kommt einfach immer auf die sorte des
mehls
und jetzt hier stufe 2 schön kneten ich
habe die kenwood ich kann sogar ein
bisschen hitze darauf geben dann wird
die vergleichbar so 32 grad seien
optimal und stand heißt sich dabei schon
mal während des knotens auf und dann
geht der gärprozess später schneller
[Musik]
schon jetzt dazu dass darauf tippen und
dann läuft es da rein hat nicht von
damit im besten
sehr gut
jetzt an diesem tag einfach nur etwa
zehn minuten kneten damit er richtig
schön geschmeidig
sehr gut aus
wenn wir den deckel drauf dann bleibt ja
auch schön war
der teig ist fertig samira hat gesagt
ich soll widerrufen wenn es wichtig wird
hayek netten war jetzt so unwichtig
hatte ich solche widerrufen wenn wir
dann die brötchen
und die konsistenz ist jetzt so ein
bisschen
boxplay also ein bisschen öl und der
teig der klebt jetzt auch nicht ich habe
jetzt auch noch ein bisschen mehl dazu
gegeben waren sie zwei esslöffel
ungefähr es ist ja im prinzip alles
komplett abgemessen außer dieser größe
das heißt wenn ihr mal
[Musik]
es kommt darauf an wie groß die eier
sind denn wenn ihr habt ach ich lass es
einfach weg
das eiweiß was man dazu gibt das
verändert die konsistenz und da es keine
genauen eier gibt muss man damit ein
bisschen
ich nehme ich den teig einmal kurz raus
[Musik]
und jetzt einmal eine schöne kugel
daraus formen
und man könnte den teig wieder in die
schüssel zurückgeben
und entweder mehr drauf schulen oder
auch nochmal wachs prey und das ganze
dann abgedeckt für etwa eine stunde auf
gehen lassen bis er sich verdoppelt hat
oder ihr könnt die kenwood nutzen und
die hitze wieder einstellen dann
reduziert sich auf ungefähr auf 40 45
minuten oder ihr nehmt den dampf
backofen mit der stufe da hat man dann
den dampf dass der teig ähnlich
austrocknen und da dauert wirklich nur
so etwa eine halbe stunde
aber ich mache das jetzt kurz in der
maschine und kann in der zwischenzeit
schon mal die fühler zu brechen jetzt
habe ich hier schon mal zutaten für
füllung eins nämlich die pizza füllung
dafür habe ich hier eine rote paprika
etwas kaschiert käse sonntaz cavalese
ihr könnt auch in gouda oder mozzarella
nehmen zurück da könnte aus aluminium
oder eine vegetarische füllung zu
bereiten peperoni so ein bisschen für
die würze und oregano und jetzt nehmen
wir einfach alle zutaten und würfelt sie
feind im hintergrund läuft übrigens noch
der teig das nämlich auch gleich fertig
und so ein bisschen die weiße haut
entfernen
dann alles möglichst fein würfeln
ich wollte jetzt so eine typische pizza
füllung machen das ist eher so eine
typische morath pitzer füllung mit
schock und peperoni
könnte ja mal sagen was für euch die
typische pizza füllung ist stoppt das
sieht nämlich bei jedem ein bisschen
anders aus und da jetzt hier supercup
und die peperoni brauche ich jetzt auch
kein salz und pfeffer ansonsten wenn ihr
zug weg lasst und er mit gemüse arbeitet
solltet ihr die füllung schon noch ein
bisschen würzen mit salz und pfeffer
weil sonst jetzt glaube ich schon ein
bisschen matsch
[Musik]
die
das war schon jetzt noch das gewürz rein
und kurz alles verrühren und
dann ist die erste füllung schon fertig
die ständig kurz zur seite und holt wind
die zutaten für die zweite füllung für
die zweite füllung nehme ich den hier
den käse den 60-prozentigen von gaza das
sondern ganz milde käse der aber
eigentlich schafkäse schmeckt nur eben
aus kuhmilch besteht und deswegen ist er
eben nicht so wie sage ich da nicht so
stark wie eben schafskäse für alle die
es nicht mögen und dann nehme ich noch
petersilie dazu und das ist eigentlich
so die standard füllung für porsche die
petersilie kann ich jetzt beim packen
dann kommt die samira bestimmt gleich
zum brötchen füllen wieder dazu wenn es
wieder spannend wird
ich muss sagen als kind fand ich
petersilie nicht so lecker in den
brötchen aber heute mittlerweile mag ich
gerne
das jetzt ganz fein
ich denke sehr zerbröselt die am besten
einfach mit den händen und könnt das
ganze dann vermischen
[Musik]
ok jetzt haben wir beide füllungen da
hilft es aufgegangen jetzt geht es ans
brett vor
wir können jetzt mit bisschen mehl oder
auch mit verarbeiten und das jetzt
einfach so
schön
und dann wird das ganze portioniert aber
ist echt so eine perfekte konsistenz da
brauchen wir echt keinen mehr dazu wir
machen jetzt 24 brötchen
und daher teile ich das jetzt so 1
erstmal einen kreis
dann haben wir ja den toten ein teil der
ist immer ganz praktisch wenn ihr könnt
es jetzt auch hier vierteln und dann
eben noch mal unterteilen oder ihr nehmt
den torten einteiler
zwölf portionen und die dann einfach
nochmal halbieren
du magst nach hier datei kann ja
hättest du mit deinem kugeln machen
und die bildung ja
aber wenn du ein bisschen
pferd brauchst kannst du hier nehmen
und dann entweder in der hand formen so
oder wenn du willst auch hier auf der
matte und dann zwar immer
ich weiß nichts
gemein und zwar immer dann mit den
fingern so von außen nach innen
so
und zwar drücke ich immer mit den
fingern nach außen damit sich seine haut
darüber bildet und dann wird schön glatt
aber
du kannst auch in der hand machen wenn
es nicht anders geht
[Musik]
bis zum 100
ok und jetzt werden die brötchen gefüllt
das heißt du nimmst jetzt immer einen
teil
eröffnet den ganz leicht
unternehmen einen mittleren eis
portionierer
eine funktion hiervon
es kommt dann da rein
guck mal kurz zu ein bisschen weiter auf
ich mache das hier mit ja
und dann einfach an den seiten
hochklappen und schwingt zusammen
denkst du dir schmecken gut
also ich weiß es und dann legen wir
nicht aufs blech und fertig
[Musik]
sagen die pizza füllung ist bisschen
kniffliger
die pid service kniffliger als die
andere die klebt nämlich besser zusammen
aber es geht trotzdem ihre gegner oder
mancher papa wird es auch hinkriegen
ich weiß nicht
das war diplomatisch ausgedrückt du mit
deiner genau als der letzte dann passt
das perfekt
und dann kann man den käse füllung
machen
ach so ja okay dann fragt sicherung der
käse verlinkt wie sehe ich das machen
und damit aber wartet
einmal für das letzte und
damit das ist einfacher weil sich der
käse so ein bisschen der klebt damit
zusammen gewonnen und dann sitzt die
kugel besser
dann führen wir jetzt die käse teilt ihr
noch fertig und dann hole ich gleich
noch die zwei eigelb die ich jetzt übrig
habe dann ist eiweiß ist er im teig
eignet habe ich noch da und dann kann
man die nämlich packen und der vorteil
jetzt hier bei dem teig ist ich habe
jetzt auch das backen benutzer
backpulver mit drin hefe es aber auch
drin sind wir sind doppelt gemoppelt
aber ich mache es tatsächlich ganz gerne
bei solchen brötchen ich lass dir jetzt
nicht mehr aufgehen und stellen sie
gleich in den kalten backofen so spart
man sich echt ein bisschen zeit
[Musik]
okay sagen wir hier die 2 eigelbe hier
etwas öl einfach sonnenblumenöl wird
kurz vermischt und damit bestreichen
jetzt die brötchen
die porsche
und du darfst dann will sagt und schwarz
wir können ja auf einem blech sesam und
andere spielt dann kann man so
unterscheiden wobei ich jetzt natürlich
nicht mehr weiß doch dass diese pizza
ein käse
pizza mit ja
[Musik]
jetzt bräuchten bereit für den backofen
der backofen ist jetzt noch kalt das ist
jetzt auch ganz wichtig denn entweder
lasst ihr die brötchen jetzt abgedeckten
halbe stunde aufgehen und schiebt sie
dann in den heißen ofen oder ihr stellt
das erste blech in den kalten ofen das
zweite könnt ihr dann abgedeckt stehen
lassen und das kann dann in der zeit
aufgeben und während der aufheizzeit des
backofens kann dann das brötchen einfach
schön aufgehen so könnte das auch machen
und spart halt echt schon enorm zeit ich
backe nämlich immer ganz gerne solche
dinge bei ober unterhitze und nicht bei
heißluft gleichzeitig will heißt so ein
bisschen das gebäck austrocknet deswegen
jetzt den kalten ofen dann den ofen auf
185 ober unterhitze schalten dieses play
abdecken und stand das erste blech
backen vertrag 20 bis 25 minuten und das
zweite blech dann nur noch 20
und es ging jetzt auch recht schnell
sehr nah hefeteig geknetet so ungefähr
eineinhalb dreiviertelstunde aufgehen
lassen kurz gefüllt und jetzt kann sie
schon in ordnung
[Musik]
jetzt will die porta fertig und dann
deckt ihr sehr am besten direkt mit
einem sauberen geschirrtuch ab dann
werden sie noch mal richtig schön weich
und eines museums zeigen moment moment
als dies jetzt schon weich und fluffig
2 dessen fahrer nicht
wir sind zusammengewachsen
saliha und semiha ich würde sagen sarah
probiert heute
und da darf sie einen dafür müssen
gucken wir wer ist
bis gleich
[Musik]
zarate sie probieren ja kaum
mehr frei
[Musik]
ich habe mich gefragt wie es dir geht
das sind wir zwei hier zusammengewachsen
hier mit käse
sowie wirklichkeit so probieren
[Gelächter]
natürlich der decke ich habe extra als
kleine genommen und weil
am rhein alles
leichter besser und der 60 prozentige da
ist halt einfach so richtig cremig das
richtig gut
also das war unser portal basic rezept
man muss dazu sagen bei porsche gibt
keine bestimmte form sondern es sind
einfach kleine gefüllte brötchen aber es
gibt ganz viele verschiedene nach ernten
also falls ihr wollt dass ich da noch
mal eine abwandlung davon mache für auch
was die füllung angeht oder die form
dann sagt mir jetzt
oder schreibt gerne auch in die
kommentare dann mache ich das natürlich
gerne kann schon so gemacht
das war wie die buchteln
die waren so kann man die verlinken ja
so war das mit fliege hier verdenken was
über sanierers köpfen die buchteln hier
sind die wirtin könnt ihr gerne antiken
die dann viel spaß beim nachbacken und
bis zum nächsten mal und in einem fall
gerne welche füllung eure lieblings
füllung ist also meine ist tatsächlich
käse
morata qual spitza finde ich auch gut
aber mit kartoffeln schmeckt auch gut
kartoffeln wie ich zu schwer um
kartoffeln es gibt viele die eben dann
mit kartoffel ich mag es nicht so gern
ich habe überall schwarzkümmel das macht
50 tipps und
tricks
[Musik]